die sind aus wie diese schuhe die die im
mittelalter an hat und so wenn die den
krieg ziehen
brutale sowieso domina schuhe und jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video ersten
sorry für den hintergrund ich habe
leider keine andere lösung gefunden weil
das so versteht wenn man hier aber
wahrscheinlich ist es den meisten von
euch ja auch gefallen dass die boxen da
reflektieren egal egal egal aber darum
geht es heute natürlich überhaupt nicht
ich habe mich mal wieder hingesetzt habt
was richtig geiles entwickelt eine super
neue video de also in der hinsicht habe
ich das auf youtube noch nicht gesehen
ihr könnt ja wahrscheinlich alle diese
video ich habe dazu glaube ich auch
schon mal ein video gemacht ich erwarte
frauen produkte oder ebenso entscheidung
ist die idee kommen dass vielleicht
nochmals machen aber diesmal nicht mit
irgendwelchen frauen produkten sondern
lediglich mit schuhen weil jedes mädchen
jeder in mädchen diesmal jedes mädchen
hat ja fast so viele schuhe ich habe
viele schwören
so bestimmt so 12 113 114 auf jeden fall
hat er jedes mädchen oder jede frau sehr
sehr viele schuhe und schule sind ja gar
nicht mehr so günstig natürlich gibt's
juli sind günstig jahr schon wieder viel
zu lange oder ja auf jeden fall erwarte
ich einfach den preis von frauen schuhe
ich hab noch mehr schuhe und wenn ihr im
zweiten teil volt da ja ich hab noch mal
so viele schuhe dann wenn du das noch
mal sehen
50.000 ja ich will gar nicht lange
lagern weil diesen schuhen handelt es
sich wirklich um frauenschuhe als es
sind keine unisex uhr diese schuhe
werden wirklich als frauen zu verkauft
also jetzt keine schuhe von snipes die
eigentlich jeder tragen kann also nicht
so dass nico mich und ich würde sagen
wir fangen sofort machen ich bin echt
gespannt weil ich kann das wirklich
glaube ich das ist eine sache die kann
ich echt nicht schätzen
wir werden sehen und ich würde sagen gib
mir doch einfach mal den ersten schub
guck mal der ist so lange da passen sich
darauf die kamera drauf also hier haben
wir jetzt eigentlich organisch die
feldarbeit hast du dazu noch ein okay
jetzt vor allem bei diesen schuhen ist
es wirklich meine meinung nach total
schwer weil ich kann mir das gar nicht
vorstellen ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass es solche schuhe gibt die wirklich
unfassbar teuer sind also irgendwie so
1000 euro
aber die kann es bestimmt auch in so 100
200 euro geben oder haben wir hier eine
marke doc oder ist es ist das von
irgendwann marke ist es war wirklich
nicht besonders gut da soll ich einfach
mal 65 eur 55 gast ist ja echt günstig
alter ich habe mich alleine ich habe
mich ein paar schuhe was sich hilfe ein
ich muss das noch mal sagen wir waren
noch mal runter gesetzt als ich die
geholt habe und dementsprechend auch
also ich hatte schon echt kernbank
einfach nur für die also sage ich mal so
für die schule wieder eine stelle
zurückzuschicken deswegen habe ich auch
behalten weil die nicht so mega schlecht
sind vor allem von rettig
im absatz aber sitzen hier oben voll
reiche nation ja diesen ist nicht ganz
so toll also noch nichts mein okay wenn
ich hat sie lieb hast du das erklären
wollte ist in wirklichkeit gar nicht
doch dort also ich haben wir ganz ganz
tolle markenschuhe von der marke guess
dies ist aber auch schon länger oder ein
bisschen bis 10
also ich finde solche schuhe sehen doch
eigentlich echt brutal aus damit kann es
auch leute umbringen oder was ist die
schule ganzen welt
also ich finde da sieht für mich schon
relativ wertvoll aus ich würde einfach
mal sagen 180 euro nein
ok eigentlich so relativ richtig also
der 180 euro kostet aber ich hab den 100
euro grenze aber das sind ja nicht dass
das geht ja darum wie viel die
ursprünglich kosten ja okay dass ich
weiß genau dass ich die auf jeden fall
für 80 euro gekauft hat war nie waren
160 ihr könnt ja in die kommentare
schreiben welchen schuh ihr am besten
findet okay weil das ding ist das ist ja
nicht mal einen
ja das kann man schwer sagen so das
könnte ja auch ein junge sein team sind
das sneaker 100 euro als ich habe mir
mehr gekocht die gibt es in
verschiedenen modellen und sind zwischen
50 und 70 euro ich habe dir halt nicht
selbst gekauft werden kann
irgendwie habe ich langsam das gefühl
frauenschuh sind viel günstiger guck mal
sogar diese schuhe dann die dastehen
weil ich habe zwar umsonst bekommen
arbeiten die kosten eigentlich 130 euro
die sind aus wie diese schuhe die die im
mittelalter anhalten so wenn die ohg
krieg ziehen
brutale sowie so dominant schuhe so voll
ich kann mir das so vorstellen so das
sind halbschuhe sag mal so es gibt ja
männer die stehen darauf ihnen
geschlagen zu werden oder so und es gibt
nur videos die wurden früher bei uns
immer in der fünften und sechsten
klassen gezeigt wo alte frauen männer so
voll india treten und so sehen sich die
studios die frau dann also ich finde
jetzt echt grausam die schule also ich
würde sagen es ist zwar hässlich aber
100 150 euro bei denen weiß ich dass sie
um die 40 euro kosten ich habe sie
nämlich nicht selbst gekauft
geschenkt bekommt also sozusagen
geschenkt bekommt ich dachte mir
aussuchen die sind zwar total hässlich
aber ich hätte sie jetzt trotzdem so auf
150 geschätzt ihr könnt ihr mal kurz in
die kommentare schreiben findet ihr
diesen schuh schön schreibt einfach
schön oder hässlich handykarten
kombinieren so machen wir weiter kommen
wir zum nächsten schuljahr das weiß ich
ja dass im acud 220 nein
doch der hat mich 22 gekostet theurer
180 dann war das aber nur weniger armut
hallo wer kinder sind jetzt auch richtig
eklig aus 20 er kann sich eigentlich
manchmal
vielleicht an die vorletzte war du musst
ein bisschen lotterie an uns verständigt
und das vorletzte paar habe ich ja schon
das sind die haben wir den absatz noch
so stimmt dass sie sind so genannten sox
gehört
gummi kann sich jetzt hat ich habe jetzt
in der hand worten rate mal so wir haben
hier ja die sind ja von zara die sind ja
auch das ist ja ich meine gut ich kann
es auch nicht verstehen wenn halt schon
echt toll wenn schule so für 500 euro
verkauft werden aber ich würde niemals
schuhe von zara kaufen hält diesen fall
gut außerdem wie gesagt ich habe eine
andere schuhe ja dann sage ich mal 15
euro
25 nein mit 80 80 den man ja teurer und
wenn ich jetzt als junge zuzahlungen und
schuhe kauft würde wenn ich bei 20 euro
können gefahren bin eben gerade weil
sich keiner kurz meine anderen schule
die ich habe kurz auf dem handy raus aus
dem bett zeigen ja leute hier haben wir
wieder das ist doch wieder ins nie
können gibt es auch für jungs von dieser
marke von 80 glaube ich ja aber es ist
ja wahr jetzt kein schuh dabei wirklich
so wo ich wo ich das gar nicht
einschätzen konnte ich meine ich bin
jetzt von mir selber positiv überrascht
indem sind ab so damit ich jetzt
vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
herausgefordert werde sucht jetzt
einfach mal bilder raus von den schuhen
diesen auch zu hause hat ja hallo wo es
dann halt vielleicht noch ein bisschen
schwerer werde also bis sechseinhalb
stunden später von zu hause noch drei
paar schuhe rausgesucht also im internet
geht das ich bin jetzt in windows movie
maker jetzt denkt man ja das steht ja
schon der preis soll man hasst das jetzt
gelesen
vorhin habe ich mich ja von armani ja
hier warst du ja würde ich möchte dich
kannst jetzt da ich super bilder und
dann ist er zu hause gucken
du hast nein habe ich nicht 320 sollte
ich nein
er warte teurer oder günstiger also
diesen jetzt gebraucht man günstiger
dass obama manie geht jemand tasche von
armani
ich habe dann hab ich das und louie vito
vorwärts mit louie vito wie beton geht
nicht hier die sind jetzt gebrauchen da
steht zwar 20
es geht doch darum wie teuer die wahl
wenn die gerade raus kommen
meine beine haben 250 neuen gekostet und
ja darum geht's also leute ich habe 200
gesagt die kosten 250 neue ok willkommen
zum nächsten plan die sind von marc
o'polo
bei uns gibt es auch so ein marco polo
der macht pizza die sind jetzt aber
schon teuer wenn sich die tipps geben
okay dann sag ich jetzt einmal die
kosten 350 dollar weniger als 280 es
waren wir 20 230 zweimal hat ihr könnt
ja in die kommentare schreiben wie ich
mich so gemacht habt das gerne daumen
nach oben ich war gut das gerne daumen
nach oben da schaut mal bei marie nicht
finster im vorbei ist hier auch gerade
gar nicht eingeblendet
also leute wir sind und sonntag wieder
bis sonntag 3 mit v